In pretrial hearings
today, the judge
overseeing the $1.6 billion
defamation lawsuit brought by Dominion
voting systems
against Fox
tore into the network
today, saying he was concerned, quote,
there have been misrepresentations
to the court
day after saying Fox
had a, quote, credibility problem.
Both comments were about Rupert Murdoch's
role in the network.
The judge said he plans to appoint
an outside attorney
called a special master
to investigate whether Fox lied
and withheld key evidence.
Dominion argues
that Fox narrowly defined Murdoch's role,
limiting what Fox turned over
during Discovery.
Now, it happened a day
before jury selection begins
and after a series
of damaging revelations
about the network.
Randi Kaye has that part of the story.
The outcome of our presidential election
was seized from the hands of voters.
Fox News
host Tucker
Carlson backing
former President Donald Trump on air.
But private text messages
sent by Carlson released
as part of the Dominion
Voting Systems lawsuit
against Fox News show
how he really feels about Trump.
According to the messages, Carlson
actually hates
Trump passionately
and views his presidency as a disaster.
Two days before the Capitol
insurrection, Carlson wrote,
We are very, very close
to being able to ignore Trump.
Most nights, I truly can't wait.
On January six, Carlson
texted his producer calling Trump
a demonic force, a destroyer Carlson
described Trump's post-election behavior
as disgusting.
Is the fix already in?
It wasn't just Carlson.
Other Fox hosts who repeatedly featured
Trump's election fraud claims on air.
Nobody like Dominion voting systems
were also mocking Trump
and his lawyers behind the scenes.
Court documents reveal Fox
anchors and executives
used words
like ludicrous
mind blowingly nuts and totally insane.
Carlson texted other hosts,
including Laura Ingraham,
about Trump lawyer Sidney Powell,
saying, Powell is lying, by the way,
I called her.
It's insane, Ingraham responded.
Sidney is a complete nut.
No one will work with her.
Court documents released in the case
also include an email
from Fox Chairman Rupert Murdoch
describing Trump's
election lies as bull and damaging.
In Murdoch's January deposition,
he conceded
that some Fox hosts were endorsing
Trump's falsehoods about the 2020
election being stolen.
Murdoch said,
I would have liked us to be stronger
in denouncing it in hindsight.
Murdoch's deposition
also reveals
that he rejected
his own network's
conspiracy theories about Dominion.
When asked by Dominion's lawyers,
Do you believe that Dominion
was engaged
in a massive
and coordinated effort to steal the 2020
presidential election?
Murdoch replied, No.
Promotion of the false claims
was also rejected by the network's
DC managing editor.
Court documents show.
In my 22 years affiliated with Fox,
this is the closest thing
I've seen to an existential crisis,
at least journalistically.
Bill Sammon wrote to a colleague.
Still, Fox News denies
wrongdoing and says it was reporting
on newsworthy allegations
about the election
Why were Fox hosts
saying one thing on the air
and something else privately?
Dominion contends
this was all about business
and not alienating the base
loyal to Trump.
When Fox reporters
tried to report the facts,
they were attacked.
Court filings
show Tucker
Carlson was livid
after a Fox News reporter Fact-Check
Trump's tweet about votes
allegedly being destroyed.
Carlson texted coworkers.
Please get her fired.
Seriously, what the F.
It needs to stop immediately.
Like tonight,
it's measurably hurting the company.
The stock price is down.
Not a joke.
Documents from court
also show
Fox News
Chief Suzanne Scott was furious
after a correspondent
for the network fact
checked Trump's election lies,
warning it was bad for business.
In this email, Scott
said this has to stop now.
The audience is furious
and we are just feeding them
material bad for business.
In another revealing
email, Murdoch explained
why Hannity
continued to promote election lies,
saying Hannity
had been privately disgusted
by Trump for weeks
but was scared to lose viewers.
Randi Kaye joins us now.
What stands out to you
in the details
that have emerged
in court filings by Dominion
Well, Anderson, what's remarkable
in these legal filings is
you can see how worried
Fox hosts and executives were.
They were worried about losing business.
They were also worried
about losing viewers,
certainly to Newsmax,
which was also pushing
these false election conspiracy theories.
And when you look at the whole breadth
of the text messages in the emails,
you can really see the Fox business model
at least according to Dominion.
They have said that
it's not about delivering the truth.
Dominion says
that it's about pushing content
and conspiracy theories to these viewers,
feeding them
all of that to keep them hooked.
Now, more specifically,
Dominion has alleged in the lawsuit
that Fox News recklessly
disregarded the truth
because it was more concerned
about business
and Dominion is now saying
that these emails, text messages
and also the deposition testimony
speak for themselves Anderson.
Randi Kaye, appreciate it.
Thank you.
Perspective now
from retired
First Amendment lawyer Leigh Levine
was represented
on Fox News, CNN
and many other media
organizations in his distinguished
40 years of practice.
Leigh,
when you hear the developments
in court
today, the judge
accusing Fox, his legal team
making misrepresentations,
saying he's likely to appoint
a special master to investigate.
Is that a big deal
to run afoul of the judge
like this on the eve of the trial?
Oh, yes, it is a very big deal, Anderson.
It's a big deal on three levels.
First,
one of the things that the judge said
today
was that
he was likely going to give the jury
what's called an adverse
inference instruction,
which means that he's
going to tell them that
because Fox did not produce
information in discovery
that hampered Dominion
in its ability to defend the case,
the jury can infer from that
that the information
that Fox didn't provide
would have been helpful to Dominion.
And that is coming from the judge
that will be very powerful to the jury,
especially on top of all of the emails
and texts
that you just discussed on the air.
The judge, Judge Davis, also sanctioned
Fox, basically
saying Dominion can conduct
new depositions with witnesses.
And if they do, Fox
has to pick up the costs.
I don't know
if Dominion
will actually take the judge up on that
on the offer,
if there will be other sanctions,
if you were
I mean,
if you were representing Dominion,
how would you want to proceed?
Is would new depositions mean
a halt to the trial?
Not necessarily.
There are
obviously going to be
a number of witnesses in the case,
the ones that are impacted
by the new information
that has just recently
been turned over by Fox to Dominion
are very few.
So theoretically,
those depositions could be taking place
at another location
while the trial is going on.
And Fox could make those witnesses
available both for the depositions
and then for their trial testimony.
And Dominion
could have the
advantage of having that information
gleaned from the deposition
when they actually put
the witnesses on the stand.
And this revelation is Rupert
Murdoch apparently held dual roles
at both Fox News,
as well as his parent company, Fox Corp..
Could that explain why that has.
I mean,
why does that have the potential
to be significant to
this case is just that
they didn't specify that to Dominion.
That's what Dominion is claiming.
Dominion.
And the judge as well
seems to be of the view
that that question about Rupert Murdoch's
role at Fox News,
whether he was, in fact, an officer of
the company
Fox misstated
or did not disclose that he was.
And now it has belatedly disclosed
that he was.
And the judge is very concerned
that that was a misrepresentation
that prejudiced Dominion
because it if it had known
if Dominion had known
that Murdoch
was an officer of the corporation,
it would have
arguably be entitled to a broader
array of documents
to be produced from Murdoch,
because he would have had
at least
theoretically, control
over a broader range of documents.
And they never got those documents.